[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant guest today is a
journalist and
the author of this brilliant book the
status game will still welcome to
trigonometry thanks for having me uh the
word i was also looking for is
best-selling author and my brain sort of
malfunctioned but you are in fact this
is your sixth book as you were just
telling us yeah yeah before we get into
the show tell everybody a little bit
about who are you how are you where you
are what has been your journey through
life that leads you to be sitting here
talking to us well um obviously i'm a
writer i've been a journalist for about
20 years uh you know just it's just over
20 years now um and i've been writing
books uh yeah since i was in my mid-20s
and and i've always been interested in
you know what makes people tick um you
know what drives people what makes
people believe kind of crazy irrational
things and that that's def that's been
the theme throughout my a lot of my
journalism and certainly my books
yeah well yes indeed and what you know
the status game seems to me to be going
to the very fundamentals of what makes
us tick yeah we were talking before we
started about our former guest dr mike
martin who wrote a book called why we
fight which is all about testosterone
and the desire to seek status and all of
that so if anyone's uninitiated
unfamiliar with this subject what is the
status game
well um the status game is that is the
subconscious reality of human social
life that that's how i see it you know
lots of my previous books i've been
focusing on the conscious experience of
life which is a story like the brain
processes reality and turns our life
into a story and we're the hero at the
center of our lives and we're surrounded
by this cast of characters and we're on
these amazing missions and you know so
that's that's why we tell stories in the
way that we do because we've been making
these
newer processes and in this book i
wanted to wanted to sort of take it a
bit further and go okay so if the
conscious reality of
life is a story what's going on
subconsciously what's the truth
and so
the status game is is my attempt at
answering that question like what's
really going on under the hood and
and i think a lot of
a lot of human social life is about two
things so connection and status so so
because of our tribal evolution we're
compelled to um connect into groups of
like-minded people and then once we're
in those groups compete for status
and we see that all the way through our
society and in particular one of the
things that you focused on was virtue
people competing to be the most virtuous
absolutely so yeah i think to understand
this you've got to understand where
where the kind of the status game comes
from and that's in our tribal evolution
we know dr mike martin talks a lot about
kind of dominant status which is which
is which is the oldest kind of form of
status very probably and we've been
competing for status with dominance
since we were before we're human you
know it's fighting it's threat it's it's
violence um it's bullying ostracization
all those kinds of things but once we
settled down and started living in you
know communities um
competing with violence wasn't very
useful so we had to
you know evolve new ways of competing
for status and those news new ways were
all about kind of group life and so what
happened was we started competing for
status with the reputation
and um the way you earned stated with
reputation is you prove that prove that
you are valuable to your group you're
useful to your group and there are two
ways of being useful to your group one
of the ways is being virtuous so
generous and selfish and courageous in
battle but also following rules and
enforcing the rules when other people
don't you know don't follow them and
then the other way the hardest way is
success but being competent by being um
you know fantastic uh you know
storyteller
hunter honey finder but but but yeah i
think i think what we're going to be
talking about today is a lot of that
kind of virtue status because we're not
used to thinking of of connecting virtue
and status but of course they're
completely linked mother teresa is a
superstar the pope is a superstar you
know people see people like michelle
obama a as this kind of virtuous
superstar you know it's not really about
competence with these kinds of
characters it's all about their kind of
virtue
and people have been exploiting that
like you said from time memorial you
know if you think about the scribes the
pharisees people like that people who
position themselves as being virtuous
but it's not always religious people now
who are trying to be virtuous no no i
mean you know the the this urge to
have
status from virtue is built into us you
know we all have it to a certain degree
i mean of course we're all on the
spectrum um
and you know i think it's really
interesting in this kind of
post-religious
society we've got now because for you
know for centuries and longer um
religion was the way that we that we
principally earned status even people in
very kind of low low caste groups before
the industrial
revolution um
you know if they were like a you know a
peasant working on a farm they could
still feel like they had status because
they were a good christian and they were
doing all those good christian things
and now that's declining people still
want to pursue virtue status especially
the ones that haven't really got what it
takes to achieve the competence forms of
status
and and i certainly see that playing out
you know a lot online a lot in social
media and a lot in what we think of as
council culture well before we get into
that i i actually i think your book and
your work is so much more fascinating
than just a conversation about the
culture wars uh francis and i've always
been interested in talking to
evolutionary psychologists and
biologists and various people about some
of the underlying stuff that makes
humans who they are so
let's start by talking about that
and let's talk about bullying a word
that you just mentioned i've never
thought about it but as we were waiting
for you to come i was sort of thinking
what is the social function of bullying
because it exists in every society i
think very much so there must be some
purpose to it and is that
is that for the majority or certain
people to assert their dominance so that
they become higher status is that what
it's about yeah i i guess it depends on
what context you mean bullying but
certainly one-on-one playground bullying
is about dominance
and
um
you know children start competing for
status as soon as they start learning
how to play with other people when they
fight over who gets access to the toy
that's a symbolic status battle and
that's certainly true um uh
in the context of bullying it's a study
that i cite in the book that looked how
they looked at looked at why school
children um um you know pre-adolescent
school children tend to be bullied and
ostracized from their social groups
and it's very often when they um
when they when their behavior or
something about them makes them a threat
to the status of that social group when
they embarrass people or make them feel
uncomfortable and and that kind of
negative status kind of feels like it's
leaking out into the into into the other
the people around they'll start bullying
them and ostracizing them so and of
course you know
this kind of bullying is is always about
status it's always about taking somebody
that's there and pushing them down there
and and with your kind of active that's
the dominance you know act with an act
of dominance you know raising yourself
up so that ties then into what you're
talking about which is online uh and you
know council culture has become this
very
politicized word but i actually think
you know people will be tempted to think
that cancel culture is what people who
are right off center let's say say about
what happens to them from people left or
center i i sort of see it as a much more
universal thing that's going on and the
harassment and mobbing and bullying
happens from everybody
so is that what's driving it it's a
bunch of people who you you sort of
hinted at it don't have the ability to
to achieve status through competence
don't have the ability to achieve it
through dominance force violence etc but
here is this great tool you know you've
got a twitter account and you can go and
harass a celebrity what you know
today it's dave chappelle tomorrow it's
going to be someone else yeah is that
what it's about no status people
achieving status at the expense of
someone famous
it is but but but but the only thing
that i'd say about that is that it is
dominance behavior because dominance
isn't just about physical violence it's
about the threat of violence but it's
also about the threat of ostracization
it you know
we don't
dominance is about it you know it's
partly about one-on-one physical
competition but it's also about um
competition with reputation and you know
a person's reputation that's their kind
of avatar that's their you know what
they're playing the status game with so
if you attack someone's reputation
you're you're attacking their identity
you're attacking the core of who they
are and everything they've worked
towards the kind of locus of the meaning
of their life so so so you know
it isn't violence when we attack
reputation but it's something you know
close to it it it's a it's a dreadful
thing that we do it's i i i in the book
i thought you know i kind of explained
that there's no pure games there's no
there's no pure success game and pure
virtue game they're kind of mixtures
what is this called mixtures um
and i think kind of cancel culture and
you know
with the worst of human behavior even up
to an including genocide which i also
write about is virtue dominance play
it's virtue play because it's about you
will follow the rules you will not
insult our sacred beliefs you will not
insult our sacred symbols and if you
don't we will get you so that's that's
that dominance that kind of virtue play
and and it's fundamental it's human
behavior you know we're very good at
blaming you know mark zuckerberg and
jack dorsey for causing all these things
but they haven't caused it they've just
connected people together and when you
connect people together they're going to
play status games and this kind of thing
is going to happen but now we've got the
status game with virtue
and then we destroy people whilst at the
same time being hashtag be kind yeah
which to me is just the most
mind-blowing thing i've ever seen but
but but that's again it's just
consistent with you know that that's
part of the storytelling brain we have
this conscious experience of life and
you know in previous books i've
described the brain as a hero maker it's
very good at making us feel heroic and
justifying all our all our acts
and it's thought that the strongest bias
of all is the moral bias so so the brain
is very good at saying you know you know
fundamentally you're a good person and
you're a better person than all these
other people um
and and and that's what the be kind
thing is all about that's people's
brains doing what brains are supposed to
do which is tell a story about your own
virtue and your own superiority whilst
playing this
rather cynical status game kind of
subconsciously so and that's not unique
to the internet you know the the
the nazis thought they were on the side
of the good the communists thought
they're on the side of the good that's
just what brains do
and even when presented with objective
facts like you're literally ruining
someone's career yeah you were you were
impacting on their mental health you
were causing and creating suffering but
they deserve it right that's the
argument yes yeah exactly so that's
exactly right i mean
you've got to kind of understand a bit
how the brain works and you know one of
the things that i write about kind of
continually in my books which because i
think it's just extraordinary is the
fact that the you know the brain is
constructing a story constantly about
the world and that's literally you know
information comes in from the world and
um it constructs this
like story scape for us to live in a and
a lot of it is delusional a lot you know
it's kind of designed to
again make us feel heroic and we really
and it's really good at kind of being
very shifty with the with the objective
truth and twisting it and turning it to
make us feel that we're heroic and as i
said you know before the nazis thought
they were the heroes of that story they
genuinely thought they were and so did
the communists they genuinely thought
they were the communists thought they
were pun they said we're punching up you
know they're obviously not using our
contemporaries but they were punching up
at the you know the bourgeoisie and the
czarists and all this stuff um and in
the same way the people online are
convinced that they're punching up too
and
there's a chapter in the status game
that looks specifically at the culture
wars and what i thought was interesting
is when you look at the narratives of
the left and the right you know the two
sides of the culture war they both tell
a story um which is in part convincing
about that they're punching up and so so
the classic you know the the the kind of
extreme left cancer culture people said
they're punching up at you know you know
essentially
white people especially white men
especially straight white men and the
argument is they've hoarded all the
status they've hoarded all the power and
it's not fair and we and we're
destroying this evil elite that doesn't
deserve to be there but if you look at
the other side the right wing view it's
like well
when they look up they don't see
straight white men they see educated
people they see you know highly educated
um elite people you know people who went
to kind of ivy league universities and
oxbridge people who run the bbc and the
new york times and and they're both ways
of seeing the status game that have some
validity to them so so and i think
that's when these stories become really
dangerous because they have this kind of
kernel of truth but but their stories
they're not real they're massively
simplistic it is true that historically
in in white dominated countries white
men have had an advantage but it's
definitely true now that if you've been
to oxford cambridge or an elite
university or you work at the bbc you've
got a massive advantage over an awful
lot of straight white men who don't have
those advantages so so the brain tells
this this heroic story which is usually
really simplistic um but it's never true
it's always much more complicated than
the kind of warriors
would admit to let's come back to the
culture war in a second so france i just
want to i just want to stick with the
with the human society part of it first
so
clearly in our society now if i was
seeking to achieve higher status through
physical force that would be considered
unacceptable so societies have developed
over time
rules and regulations unspoken and
legislative
about controlling the way that people
play this game yeah
where are we now in terms of that in
terms of you know how how do we uh is
this this nature of ours which i i doubt
is ever going away realistically right
how do we regulate that in a way that
sort of makes sense in modern society
well yeah that's a really good point i
mean because i think you know for tens
of thousands of years we've been we've
been regulating principally male
violence yeah yeah and that's been going
on for for thousands of years
and to the extent that we physically
changed before
the psychologist called the process of
self-domestication we domesticated
ourselves we became much more feminized
we had you know bigger eyes and we
control the world much more by
controlling other people understanding
how minds work and being able to
manipulate them um and so and that's
that that's why that we are for for a
primate um within the people within our
group incredibly peaceful compared to
even bonobos who are famously you know a
peaceful um primate we're much more
peaceful than that so it's uh
where our aggression is is group versus
group um but but but but you know we're
much less good at regulating those other
forms of aggression which are the forms
uh which both genders use um but but
certainly
you know
women use them every bit as much as men
and that's bullying ostracization it's
the reputation destruction forms of
aggression
which
which we don't really have the checks
and balances
there um at the moment and i think
that's what needs to happen
you know especially online
that that we need to evolve new norms
that that are kind of against this kind
of
you know reputation-based dominance play
do you think the problem there is will
that with physical aggression
we are inevitably confronted by the
consequences of the nazis who you
mentioned even himmler
wrote about how unpleasant it was to
have to put all the jews in gas chambers
so you are physically confronted with
that reality and it becomes impossible
to if you start asserting your physical
dominance over me you have to see me
suffer bleed etc cry whatever it would
be even though i would never crack
but you know what i mean whereas with
this online stuff there is that sort of
windscreen effect where you're sitting
in your car someone else is in another
car and you are in a safe bubble and you
don't have to see them suffer yeah you
can do whatever you want yeah totally
yeah and that that's a huge problem and
i also think it's a huge problem just
just that form of communication like one
way of seeing social media is
as a gossip network and in you know in
the book and in previous books i've
written about the importance of gossip
to human social life you know gossip the
first forms of story um
and gossip was there you know it gossip
is universal it plays a crucial function
in human social life and it's there to
regulate it so so back in the days of
the tribe um uh you know
there was no police force there was no
judiciary there was no prison system
so so we controlled social behavior by
by gossipings and if people got a bad
reputation they'd be punished you know
with ostracization you know all of the
ways we're familiar with today up to
including execution
and but if the gossip was positive this
person did an amazing thing they'd raise
in status and become heroic so it's an
essential component of
you know we've all evolved to gossip
children begin to do kind of tattletail
forms of gossip almost as soon as they
can talk it is baked into us and then
you you've got to look at the grants of
human history
so
so
that's how we were regulating our
societies for thousands of years and
then when we settled down and community
started growing
so big that we couldn't know everybody
personally so we couldn't gossip about
everybody individually we invented the
big god religions and and so religion is
a gossip network but god knows all the
gossip and you're going to get punished
or rewarded after life so and and it was
the feeling that god was watching you
that that controlled your you know
largely controlled your behavior
um and then
you know in our kind of post-nation at
nietzsche and age where now god is dead
journalism did that job journalism
became our gossip network that's how we
tackled about especially high status
people and and you know moral outweighs
raises they will be punished and you
know we're living in a kind of
post-journalistic age now and i've lived
and worked through it where where the
norms of journalism have just collapsed
because of the internet and social media
is our new gossip network and so so it's
not just this thing that people do you
know for a laugh on their phones
the gossip network is as i said is an
essential component of human life it
plays a crucial role and it's a
pathological form of gossip network
because you know
there are barely any consequences for
spreading malicious gossip i think back
in the days of the tribe you know people
you know if you use religious gossip you
are going to get gossiped about and and
bad things could happen to you um you
know
in the glory days of journalism yes of
course there were left-wing and
right-wing newspapers fine but but there
was still pressure on journalists to get
it right to get the truth and if you
didn't get the truth you got a bad
reputation or you worked for a crappy
tabloid and everyone looked down their
nose at you anyway um but but those
norms just don't exist on that they're
scarily hard to find in traditional
journalism these days
and they barely exist on social media
you know and not only do they not barely
exist they they also exacerbate and
encourage yes these worst tendencies of
people that's the problem isn't it yeah
exactly everything you attach status to
we're gonna flock to it i mean in in the
book i talk about this status game that
um anthropologists found on an island um
in micronesia which is based on yams and
the idea was whoever brought the biggest
yam to the feast
was declared number one in the feast and
that was the thing and he's raising
status and so what happened on the
island was that it was a kind of a male
game this all the men just became
obsessed with the growing yams and they
became amazing at growing yams they
would crawl out their bed at two in the
morning to go into their secret yamp in
the forest to tend to it and stroke it
and feed it first lighter and there are
stories there of yams that were so big
it took 12 men to carry them into the
feast on a special stretcher so that's
that's humans you know if you attach
status to something we're going to do it
and we're going to do it big and you're
absolutely right you know these days
you're attaching status to these extreme
political beliefs um you're attaching
status to to the ability to to to tear
your kind of ideological enemies down so
that's what we're going to do and that's
what we're doing so so so it's yeah it's
a it's a pathological
gossip network that incentivizes this
kind of virtue dominance form of status
game
but it's also made the status game worse
it's made it more toxic much more toxic
yeah i i i i absolutely has i mean
one of the things that i write about
again in the book is this idea of the
moral panic i kind of just kind of
readdressed what is a moral panic and i
and i look at the
um satanic panic in the 1980s as a form
of moral panic but actually i think when
you look at it from the status point of
view it's not really a moral panic i
call it a status gold rush because what
you've got is this is this small group
of therapists um that hit upon this way
of becoming incredibly rich incredibly
famous and um you know interviewed on
oprah um hosted at big conferences and
um you know interviewed by academics um
and you know perhaps more important than
even the money and the fame is is that
kind of story they're allowed to tell
themselves that we're saving the world
you know we're saving the world's
children from the forces of evil and so
what happened during that was that it
was that flocks of people were drawn to
this satanic panic um status game in
which
uh
you know the idea was that these
therapists were and police officers were
seeking out secret satanic sex abusers
um
and you know and it was a disaster it
spread throughout um the us it came to
the uk you know dozens of people had
long prison sentences for doing things
they couldn't possibly have done like
you know throwing children at sharks and
stitching their eyelids shut during a
kindergarten and then somehow returning
the kids to their parents unharmed at
the end of the day like mad stuff
and and and you know i think it makes
much more sense when you see that i'd
see the idea of a status gold rush that
it wasn't a moral panic that was that i
don't think it was driving the satanic
panic it was a status gold rush all
these people with ordinary lives just
therapists just family experts suddenly
became famous rich and
that they felt they were saving the
world from the forces of evil and i
think that's what we see on social media
too it's a it's a you know it's a status
gold rush there are millions and
millions of just ordinary people with
ordinary lives who suddenly feel that
they're fighting the good fight against
the forces of darkness and you know
we're going to tear down dave chappelle
or whoever it is or kathleen stock or
whatever it is and and and
you know you got to understand that
status is is an immeasurably valuable
resource it's a basic human need if we
don't feel that we have status we become
mentally unwell depressed even up to
feeling suicidal if our status is taken
away from us
in a kind of dramatic way we even become
physically ill if we don't feel that we
have sufficient status so it's an
immeasurable measurably valuable
resource and what social media has given
us isn't able to do is is is to gather
that resource
um
in such a way that we have so you know
we have more status in our online lives
and we do in our real actual lives so
that's really valuable to people and
that's
you know that's what their brains want
their brains aren't particularly
interested in in finding out the truth
their brains are interested in how do i
get status well and is this why people
are so fearful of humor and comedy
because comedy is one of the most
powerful ways to take status away from
things when you mock something even
playfully you are taking away the
significance from it and
we saw it you know the comedians i grew
up watching in the in the 90s there were
the bill hicks is the george collins
they went after religion because the
religious right at that time had quite a
lot of cultural significance and
dominance and these people were taking
that away and now you see when it's
flipped and it's the far left that's got
this uh cultural dominance they fear
comedy they they're terrified of it and
they're fighting against it because it
takes away the significance and the
status that they've tried to give to
their beliefs is that why yeah
absolutely i mean a basic you know a
basic way that back in the days of the
tribe that we would we we would manage
people's behavior social behavior is if
we were gossiping about them
and the gossip was bad you'd begin by
mockery and huma you know a bit of
mockery and humiliation you know that so
that's that's that again that's a as an
elemental kind of form of human behavior
so yeah and it's a way of it so it's a
way of drawing people down and that's
exactly right i grew up you know in the
90s i'm a gen xer i remember watching
bill hicks on channel 4 late one night
and having my mind just blown
and and you know i grew up in a catholic
family and in those days it was that you
know especially in america the catholic
right that were dominating and and
judging people's moral behavior and i
was a big metal fan and they were trying
to ban all the records that i that i
liked and it has flipped these days it's
the it's that you know i've always
identified as a left-wing person i still
do but it's it's the left that doing
that these days it's the section of the
left is it well it's a section of the
left absolutely yeah and you know i
don't think it's a as as you point out
it's a coincidence that these are the
people now that the comics are going
after
and we talk about humiliation
you used a very powerful example of the
power of humiliation when you were
talking about i forget his name
elliot rodgers yes elliot rodgers and
what happened to him if you could go
into that a little bit yeah so i mean
when i was thinking about the book and
whether whether there was a book in this
i kind of set myself a test and that
test was okay if you're going to argue
that status is so important then
what happens when our status is taken
away it must be pretty bad so so you
know i started looking into that and the
idea of humiliation because that you
know one of the technical definitions of
humiliation is it's the it's not only
the removal of your status it's the
removal of your ability to claim stages
in the future
you're so
you're so down there that you're just
gone basically nobody wants to have
anything to do with you ever again
and and it turns out that that is a
catastrophic thing for for
for humans to experience i if it's
serious and it's
and it's chronic it goes on and on and
on once one researcher described
humiliation as an annihilation of the
self and humiliation is is found in the
backgrounds of lots of serial killers
terrorists honor killers i mean if you
think you know it's implicated in
genocide the humiliation of the nation
or the racial group and they fight back
um
so if you think about the very worst of
human behavior you'll find humiliation
in there so that that to me was like
okay this is i think this is right about
status i think it is this important and
so i i tell the story of elliot rogers
in some detail because he's a so he's a
spree killer he's one of these kind of
in-cell spree killers but before he he
died um he left uh he uploaded to the
internet 108 000 word autobiography
which is um was called my twisted world
um and it's an extraordinary it's a
truly extraordinary document i mean
you know it's chilling
but he's
it's fascinating because
you know so in the book
i i say that the most dangerous people
probably on earth are narcissistic
people so people who believe that
they're entitled to high status and they
expect to be treated as if they're
important
and they're humiliated so when you
humiliate a narcissist
it's it's bad because because they're
dropping down a hell of a long way and
and and and if they're male and if
you're male you're much more likely to
respond with violence that's another you
know factor so grandiose
male and humiliated are this kind of you
know
these three kind of red flags and elliot
rodgers was definitely an example of
that i mean
his book uh is is sort of greasy with
its descriptions of his wonderfulness he
he describes himself as a as a beautiful
gentleman and things like this and and
thinks he's gorgeous and wonderful and
can't understand why we're not falling
at his feet um but but he's also
unflinching in his depictions of of how
miserable his life was and how he was
bullied and and hated by everybody that
he essentially went to school with
um and after he did his spree killing um
the narrative across the media left and
right was that
the cause of what he did was his
obsession with the game world of
warcraft um and they said because it's a
violent game and you're killing stuff so
that's you know makes sense right um but
i agree in the book that's actually not
true that actually world of warcraft was
his only source of status and if you
actually read his book it's only when he
stops playing world of warcraft that he
goes completely insane
and so so he describes basically
achieving the enormously stateful
experience of achieving kind of the top
level of world of warcraft and when he's
playing world of warcraft it's he's not
worrying about school he's not worrying
about girls and being popular he's happy
um and then he finds out that the people
the friends who he's playing world of
warcraft with he discovers that they've
been meeting up in secret behind his
back to play without him which is
heartbreaking for him because you know
and he describes playing the game with
sears rolling down his face because he's
so crushed by this realization so he
stops playing and literally the day he
stops playing he confides to his last
remaining friend this bizarre vision he
has of the world now in which he he
wants sex to be abolished completely
because
as far as he's concerned um the the
problems of the of the world are the
fault of women because women choose who
to have sex with and they keep choosing
you know jock aggressive types so they
keep procreating with these people and
giving birth to more aggressive jock
types so his solution is he hasn't seen
millennials
yeah yeah well this is pre this is free
then and so he's and so he wants to wipe
out all the women um and keep a few in
in a lab um to um uh artificially
inseminate to keep the um to keep the to
keep the population going well at least
he had a vision yeah yeah but but so
when i read that so when you hear that
you just think that's mental that's
mentally ill like that is gone right um
and um it's about as misogynistic as you
can get it is you can't really get many
much more misogyny to want to annihilate
all women
um but then when you look at that in the
context of the second world war
that is exactly the sort of story that
the nazis told about the world when when
the german nation which was a grandiose
nation you know the most successful
nation in continental europe before the
first world war utterly humiliated by
the treaty of versailles um
and that's the story that
you know it's not a nation of germans
because they weren't all nazis but but
that was the story that the nazis told
about the world was the eliot rogers
story but it's instead of women it was
jews so when that kind of connected to
me i just thought that that's
extraordinary because
it i think it shows you that it's
something innate in us when we feel that
our status has been unfairly taken from
us that's when we're i think our most
irrational and our most aggressive and
you've never very neatly brought us back
to the culture war there because
one of the arguments that you laid out
and this is something i've been very
concerned about for some time now
you know you talked about how people on
the right and the left have their own
simplified versions of of what's
happening and
it makes perfect sense but particularly
the far left one is the one that
troubles me um and the reason it
troubles me more is that the narrative
of the far left as you put it yourself
is that there's this group of people
who've been historically very privileged
they've got all the advantages they've
had hoarded all the status
and we must now humiliate them i mean
that is the narrative yeah right yeah so
you've got a very large group of people
uh who are as you've said for
physiological and biological reasons are
much more prone to violence another than
other groups men
they are the vast majority of society
uh white people in in the country in the
uk certainly and in america
uh and you have a driven campaign
that at least to me seems like that is
supported by media organizations by
institutions of government
by uh authorities the police the
healthcare system everywhere there seems
to be that it it's at least allowing
that to happen right those systems
now given what you've said
to me that seems a very dangerous game
to be playing it is i think it is a very
dangerous game to be playing and you can
see a little bit of it in the
trump and brexit events of 2016.
you know i think it's it's it's been
it's been commented before it's not news
that the the lots of the people that
voted for those things were white
working class and low middle class
people
whose living standards have declined in
in the last few decades but also that
their sense of status has declined you
know you know there used to be respect
in being a working-class person um and
now that you know the media decries them
as you know deplorables and trailer
trash and
you know you've got labour politicians
tweeting union jacks and going oh
you know and i think it's true that
trump and brexit was a reaction against
that it was like no you [ __ ] you know
you've got to stop treating us like this
and that and that's that's their story
of you're the educators elite who you're
looking down looking down your noses at
us and there's a there's a definite
truth to that and i and i do i i do
worry about this and i do think it's
true that there's
there's a generation of young men that
are being raised today
in canada the us and the uk who are
being raised in an in in a world in
which
men white men are just bad they're
responsible for all the bad things in
the in the world and the morally correct
thing to do is to put them to the back
of every queue um
and to not give them any of the
important jobs and you know and and to
hold them back
and that's dangerous
and because because because what's going
to happen well one of two things you
know
either they're going to internalize
those ideas and and just to suffer
terrible self-esteem
and and depression thinking i'm a white
man i'm terrible i'm awful i'm i'm i'm
i'm i'm a disaster
i need to i need to just step back and
and let everyone else have a life and
and not me or more likely they're going
to become really [ __ ] angry and
they're going to push back and you know
i i i do think we're going to be seeing
that increasingly i mean you know i i'm
in this kind of small world of
publishing there was a very interesting
story that was published in the observer
a few weeks ago that talks about the
kind of the female domination of the
publishing world and i think that's
absolutely true that's happening um the
bookseller the trade um the the the
trade paper of the book industry um a
few months ago that two months ago
published their um list of the rising
stars of the book industry and somebody
worked out they were 85 female and i
don't know if that's true or not exactly
but if you look at that cover of the
bookseller magazine it's hunt the white
man i mean i think there's one there in
this huge constellation of faces and
that and no one was talked about that it
was just accepted as this is the future
you know so if you're a young white man
that loves reading and loves publishing
and is desperate to become a publisher
and you see that how are you going to
react and i just think if he
i i i say if it continues i think it's
going to continue because no one's
pushing back against this
you are i think in a few years going to
see the resurgence of a significant
men's rights movement i mean at the
moment the men's rights is a joke
because people just laugh at it um you
know often for good reason but i think
it's going to stop being a joke
you know at some point in in the coming
years because what it needs that
movement is someone charismatic yeah
someone to come in someone who can you
know get people together someone who can
mobilize a group and then once that
happens
you know it's ready to explode isn't it
it is ready to explode and and you know
i don't want to say that uh jordan
peterson was was you know
you know
yeah i mean he
he he wasn't a men's rights activist i
don't think in that sense but but i
think what jordan peterson did show was
two things one was as you say that
there's a huge feeling out there that
that you know men absolutely flocked to
him
and the other thing i thought about the
jordan peterson kind of phenomenon was
that was that
in my journalistic career i've written
i've written about men's issues i've
written about male suicide i've written
about male survivors of sexual violence
and and so you know i've thought a lot
about male pain
and um you know in in my corner of the
world a left-wing corner of the world a
very kind of feminist kind of focused
corner of the world the idea of male
pain is something to be laughed at it's
like are you joking it's ridiculous i
mean you don't talk about it you know
it's a kind of thing to be mocked and i
think you know i think what was
fascinating about jordan peterson was
that he he actually understood male pain
you know he said i i know that you're
hurting and i understand that you're
hurting and i feel it and i care and and
that was just
you know electric and and so it was a
you know when he was at his peak um
before he got sick it was extraordinary
to see and i and i think what he did was
he just pricked at that uh that that
growing feeling of upset that there is
in the kind of in the masculine world at
the moment because we were in this weird
situation where
you're not supposed to talk about it
because if you talk about it you're the
enemy
but it's there but the other thing
jordan did which i thought was very
important is that he emphasized for men
and women because his message resonates
with the people of uh i nearly said of
all genders [ __ ] you know
all nine hundred and sixties
his message resonated with them
my point was that he
forced people to understand
that in a society
that we live in now
competing on dominance
and competing on virtue are not really
roots to happiness
the best way to compete and be happy is
to compete on competence yeah that's the
point that i think he always emphasized
which is why
i i was very frustrated at the reaction
to jordan
from people of the persuasion that you
were describing earlier because i don't
think he was saying
uh or trying to lead a movement of men
to recapture their primitive state and
go in what he was saying is if you want
status in the society that yes looks
down on you at the moment the way to
achieve status is competence be better
yeah be better take responsibility yeah
achieve more create more show the world
that what you're doing is valuable and
the world will reward you for it that's
what you're saying and to me the
reaction to jordan peterson was so
disappointing precisely because of that
because i see i see him as an agent of
detoxifying yeah all of that anger and
all of that unpleasantness that you
refer to but instead he was treated as
being the very head of that movement
yeah i just thought it was such a
catastrophic misinterpretation of it
yeah i don't i don't think i've ever
seen a public figure so misunderstood
destroyed pizza now i have to say i mean
i mean i i became aware of him
again because am i interested in the
story said in brain my book before the
stages game was the science of
storytelling and i was researching that
and and so i came upon his videos which
talks about the psychology of
storytelling and this was kind of before
he you know the c16 stuff
and so when all that happened i just
thought this isn't this is i have not
seen any i've watched all the hours of
his videos and i've not done any of this
kind of weird you know uh version of
jordan peterson that i'm now being told
um um is there and i completely agree i
mean you know i in the in the book i
take a sort of broader view and tell the
history of the world from the point of
view of the of the status game and and i
talk about the idea of modernity
modernity is when the emphasis shifted
from playing virtue games to success
games that that's what that's about so
before the industrial revolution the
revolution before the enlightenment um
most of us are playing virtue games it
was it was honor duty religion
stay in your lane be respectful to your
superiors um you know that was life for
centuries and then it all changed you
know um post-industrial revolution we
started we had started specifically
attaching success to things like
discovering useful knowledge um making
things more efficient creating
inventions but in a bigger better faster
more and you know like with the yams
when you do that we're going to do it
wherever their status we're going to
flock to that thing and and so so yeah i
i think
you know it's counterintuitive but in
the book i argue that if you want to if
you really want to save the world if you
want to do good in the world if you
really want to be a virtuous person
actually you should play a success game
because success games are the things
that have you know saved billions of
lives through vaccinations success games
have lifted billions of people above the
poverty line
it's people you know solving problems
that have done those things not people
in churches not raw families which is
another kind of form of kind of virtue
game um
so yeah you know it's playing those
success games um that i think is is is
the real answer the real way to do good
in the world but isn't the problem as
well i'm such a negative bastard isn't
the problem as well the virtue games are
just much easier to play than success
games it's easier to write a sweet guy
yeah dave chappelle is a transphobe and
he should be castrated for trans rights
right okay it's far easier to write that
tweet than it is to god to actually
castrate him yeah or to be
number one to beat dave chappelle or to
go to university to study to to study
biochemistry and then go on and do
virology and then become a urologist and
then work in whatever field it might be
that is far more difficult it requires
discipline hard work years of study 100
yeah i mean virtue is the easiest form
of status to to gain and again you know
right about that in the book
and and i think that's also why social
media is so toxic because all you've got
to do is to make it feel a bit better is
to retweet somebody with a sneery little
comment and all your followers go yeah
yeah you feel good about yourself so
it's so easy it's like popcorn status
you know you're just shoveling it down
your neck um and yeah but competence is
really hard it's difficult to become
good at something um um but but you know
and again
as somebody that's instinctively
left-wing
that that was kind of that was it took
me a while to get there because because
as a left-wing person you kind of drawn
to this virtue stuff about the to the
campaigners and and the people who
who who you feel are motivated purely by
virtue but but it's not really true i
mean those people are important they
need to be part of the mix but it's the
it's the competence people that really
are saving the world
well one of the things you've referred
to a number of times now is left and
right and i've actually tried to steer
this conversation as much from away from
that as possible because i think the
moment anything becomes about politics
it makes it more difficult for people to
hear
so you as a as a as an instinctively
left-wing person i actually i think both
from frances are in many ways as well
but
what is the difference between left and
right on these issues because it's often
said that people on the right think that
people on the left are wrong and people
on the left think the people on the
right are evil
that's that that argument is often made
but i i don't know that that i don't
know i think that's a bit simplistic you
know i i i think you you haven't got to
go back very far in history to see
right-wing people viewing left-wing
people exactly as evil you know i think
they are no
you know i think that you know in in the
kind of most stupid form of commentary
um
you see
you know right-wing people just assuming
all effing people are basically
people
communists
all the writing rules are basically
nazis and of course you know that so
what i'm getting at is there a
difference because i think it would be
fair to say that left people
prioritize emotional experiences often
more than people on the right certain
parts of the right maybe so uh not
offending people is more of a sacred
value on the left at the moment at least
yeah than than it is on the right
although as we talked about earlier 30
years ago not offending people that's
right i mean it just depends i mean
so
for these exact reasons i try to take it
away from left and right as much as
possible in the book and i came across
this across this really useful concept
um
the the psychologist most known for it
is professor michelle gelfand an
american psychologist and she writes
about tightness versus looseness and she
writes about it in in the context of
cultures but i expand that to groups the
games that we play and and so you know
it's fascinating because she says that
that there are there are tight cultures
in the world who are kind of what she
calls rule makers that they're all about
the rules and being punctual and doing
things correctly so germany is
relatively tight the uk is relatively
loose the northern states of america
relatively loose the southern states are
relatively tight um and so you know the
the tighter that you are um the more i'm
conformist you are the the more hostile
you are to outsiders um i think it's
true to say that the more likely you are
to kind of fall for the kind of wild
stories of your group so so the southern
states of america of course more
much more religious than the northern
states much more kind of
atheistic
um
and you know she's got some
extraordinary statistics you know even
down to the things like the trains run
on time better in in in tight cultures
well we knew that yes
but also like when you look at the the
clocks in public spaces are much more
likely to be in sync in a tight country
yeah but but but you can apply that to
groups too in the book i do and i write
about the kind of the tightest form of
the very tightest form of a status game
is a cult
and and so so so what occult is is we
are your only group we are your only
source of status
no other forms apply um we are your only
identity and that's why they get you to
cut off contact with friends and
relatives and all that other stuff
because that's it and we're going to
give you a very precise set of rules to
follow and if you follow this very
precise set of rules you're going to
have amazing status so you know
the famous most the most obvious example
is scientology but because i'm scared of
them i talk in the book about the
heavens gate cult and the heavens gate
cult with things like literally telling
you that you take your vitamins every
day at 7 22
telling you how much toothpaste you can
have on your toothbrush and how much
how much water you can have in your bath
so that's the tightest form of tightest
form of game and then you can loosen out
and you can see well you know political
groups like like political groups could
be tight and loose and i think left and
right the ones that are going after each
other they're tight groups they're
they're they're living a tight world
they're playing a tight game which is
about conformity and hostility to um
outsiders uh yes it's i i thought that
was useful partly because it takes it
away from left and right and you can see
throughout history
left and right that you know things
change as you as you move through as
eventually i mean look at now you talk
about the southern states and the
northern states and whatever being tight
and loose but look at covert actually
the democratic states have been much
stricter in terms of vaccine passports
vaccine mandates all of that so i guess
what what i'm hearing out of you is it
flips over time and it changes depending
on maybe who's got the physical power
the cultural power or whatever yeah i
mean a group yeah i i guess groups can
can change into in terms of tightness
and looseness but but it all depends on
on on
who whose rules that you're following
you couldn't necessarily say that the
tight southern states are looser because
they're not following rule following the
mask rules it's just that they're
following their own rules it's their
internal rules which are saying we are
liberty freedom-loving people we don't
care about the government so so they're
still conforming to rules but it's their
own particular rules that they're
conforming to and certainly you're
seeing very aggressive
um um
anti-mask people in the southern states
of the u.s um you can see some of the
behavior that kind of the anti-vaccine
communities
you know
um you're also seeing very aggressive
behavior yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and they're they're going to be tight
people too playing a tight game and and
that's what unites them is their
tightness it's their inability to deal
with other people not following their
rules right and and their compulsion to
kind of
kind of police those rules so again it's
not a left or a right or a
vax or anti-vaxx it's it's how tight you
are compared to how loose you are and
how do we get away from that how do we
get away from those extremes to a world
that is more balanced when i personally
feel that we've become more extreme
yeah i i mean in the book i write about
um
this i i think what's really important
is
is that we play many games for an
individual
so so as i said you know like like like
the most pathological wavelength
living your life is in a cult
and and it's dangerous not only because
it makes you very vulnerable to very
strongly irrational beliefs but also
what happens if you're kicked out of the
cult or the cult collapses that's your
whole identity everything that you've
ever worked
towards you know goes away
um
so in the book i write about sort of
playing a hierarchy of games this idea
that
so we know that people with a variety of
identities tend to be happier and
healthier um but because they've got
it's like a hedging they're hedging
their status that they've got you know
you've you've got lots of different ways
of earning status i'm you know i'm
interested in politics i've got this
hobby of building i know rockets or
whatever whatever whatever you're doing
i love i love architecture i've got my
job i i like to be a good parent there's
lots of different ways that you can feel
good about yourself and feel statusful
and i think that's that's the that's the
maximally healthy
kind of psychological lifestyle and so
so i think on the individual level i i
think that's what we should be trying to
do playing this kind of hierarchy of
games we've got one main game because
competence is hard as we've been saying
and you need something to focus on but
also hedging it so so that you haven't
got all your all your eggs in that kind
of um one basket
but i think societally you know i i i
you know i i think it's
i think it's happening slowly i think i
think slowly we are going to see new
norms you know
new kind of cultural status game rules
that that start sort of turning against
that kind of cancer culture narrative
you know i think at the moment you're
seeing although he's wobbling the
netflix guy you know netflix very strong
has the the the by the time this goes
out
the company could have gone bust
the hell could have been
drawn and quartered yeah
and yeah and so you are seeing you know
glimmers
because i think what i think what the
problem has been is i think we've seen
an absolute failure of leadership i
think we've seen
institutions and leaders completely fold
because it's dreadful it's it's
terrifying the idea that you're going to
be that you or the company that you lead
or the organization that you lead is
going to be the target of a cancer
culture mob and your personal reputation
and the reputation of all the people
that you care about is at risk is
terrifying so it's so it's quite glib to
say are they just a bunch of cowards
but i can understand the cowardice you
know i'm not saying i'd be any better if
i was if i was there heading up a
university or a big corporation but
but i think what's going to hopefully
going to happen is it's going to be that
that thing where the more people stand
up to this and get away with it and
actually earn status by getting away
with it earn respect and esteem by
standing up for their stuff and going no
we're not having this we're not going to
allow uh you know our team to be treated
like this and the more leaders see other
leaders achieving that i think slowly
you're going to see
finally these institutions sort of
standing up to this you know this small
minority of people who are
often dominating the narrative at the
moment and coming back to uh just
because we're sort of in the advice for
people phase of the conversation
uh one of the things that interests me
the most out of what you were talking
about as someone who's you know
uh i've been
extraordinarily wealthy
uh when my father spent a few years
being very wealthy for a very short
period of time uh we lived in a in a
former soviet bosses mansion well which
which had you know hectares of land
around the mansion and servant all of
that crazy stuff and then within 10
years i was sleeping in a park in
edinburgh with nowhere to live and no
money to pay around and whatever so i've
been up and down wow and i think
actually while my experience may sound
extreme most people have been up and
down in their life all of us have been
quote unquote down and out almost
everybody almost everybody's had the
experience of being bullied or being
humiliated or loss of status of loss of
future the loss of the future is such a
terrifying thing if anyone has ever felt
like
i don't have a future that i thought i
had it's horrific
how does one as an individual
deal with constructively loss of status
humiliation finding yourself in a
position where you feel like you have no
future how do you
rebuild yourself because as you talked
about and jordan peterson has talked
about this
physically physiologically that has an
impact right
but since it's something that we're all
going to experience there has to be a
way to get yourself out of that
situation how do you do that
yeah i mean it's easier said than done
obviously because you know obviously
status is incredibly important when we
lose it we really genuinely suffer
and and in in the in the book i talk
about this kind of this idea of
depression which is you know often
depression comes from this loss of
status this feeling that i don't have
any status and i can't think of a way to
get it and you kind of scuttle back to
the safety of the cave and you kind of
protect yourself by not taking part in
society and not trying anymore and and i
think that's the danger is is that back
of the cave kind of feeling because i
could be because i think you know the
good thing about human life especially
modern human life in the in the west um
is that we're surrounded by status games
that we that we can choose to play there
are opportunities everywhere to earn
status and and you know we talk a lot
about success games but virtue games can
also be really good you know you can
become a meditator which is a kind of
virtuous thing you can you know become a
religious person if that's if that's the
way that your kind of brain is leading
you so
so i think it's getting over that
trying to pull yourself out of the back
of the cave and think
if i can't restore my status in this
particular game from which i've been
excluded what other games can i
can i you know can i can i choose to
play you know you could volunteer for
the samaritans and and you know
literally help save people's lives
that's that's virtue play um but you
could do that tomorrow you know that if
you can do that that surely is an
amazing um source of potential status
for somebody so so yeah i i i think
that's really the answer it's just
pulling yourself out of the cave as hard
as that is as bloody painful as that is
and and as much courage as that takes
and getting out there and just trying to
find another game to play
and that is a wonderful place to finish
the interview on an upbeat note as well
um but it's brilliant before we do a
couple of uh questions for our local
supporters our final question is always
what's the one thing we're not talking
about but we really should be i've
already touched on it in the chat
actually but i've been thinking more and
more about the coming the return of the
men's rights movement you know i really
think it's coming i think it's coming
and it's going to be serious this time
and it's going to be people younger than
us um when they're hitting you know it's
the people who are maybe 13 14 now when
they get 18 19 and they're going into
this world and and if they're still
being treated like the enemy and if it
still feels like especially the
professional world i mean the arts world
that i live in if it still feels like
it's hostile to young white men i i i
think i i think
it's going to come out of the realm of
the kind of in-cell joker the men's
rights movement and it's going to start
becoming a serious a serious force so i
think that's that that's the thing that
that if we're not talking about it now i
think we are going to be talking about
it soon and we just went depressing
again i'm sorry
well that's why
like we talked about jordan peterson i
think that's why
his message and the message that other
people like him try to send out is very
very important which is
find the right game yeah because you
know even even in dating right people
you know young men complained that oh
most young women are working or
yeah sure they are but they still want a
man who's he's gonna know how to
whatever it is bleed the radiator to
take out the rub they still want that
yeah subconsciously because that's
that's how we're wired so if you are a
man who is competent you're going to be
desirable one way or another yeah so if
you work on your competence you don't
need to be angry you're going to be
rewarded for that you know
and i just think that's such an
important message and i i i hear what
you're saying and i hope that if
that sort of movement starts to emerge
then it has the right people in place
who rather than harnessing that anger
and taking a negative direction can take
those men young men and point them
towards the thing that the things that
have always made men successful yeah i
mean i think that's right i mean you
know
my wife is a is a women's magazine
editor she was editor of cosmo she's not
a javel and i and i think she's she's a
great embodiment of the positive form of
feminism which is not about she's not
about bringing men down attacking men
going on about the patriarchy she's
about empowering and encouraging women
so how can we help women be amazing it's
all positive
and and she's found great success in the
world in the magazine world by
you know she's found that when when you
put that message rather than negative
messages magazines people buy the
magazines more that's what women want
you know people want to feel i'm going
to have status you know an optimistic
positive message people respond to that
much more and i think you're absolutely
right the the the the if this if a new
men's movement does emerge it's really
important that it just doesn't become a
mirror of the worst forms of feminism
which is just you know man-hating
negative unfair portrayals of what of
what men are and this kind of paranoid
view of
of the world because that could easily
happen that kind of you know in-cell
light kind of thing um much better is is
it is the vision that i suspect jordan
peterson would endorse which is actually
you know what how can we just make how
can we encourage men to get out of that
negative space and not be paranoid and
not become misogynists and become better
men
you know more competent stronger more
courageous and not be ashamed of those
um you know those qualities which are
kind of traditionally associated with
masculinity there we go made a positive
again boom
all right everybody make sure you get
the status game we barely touched on
many of the things that you've covered
in here so make sure you grab that uh
thank you so much for coming on we're
going to do a couple of questions for
our locals but thank you for being here
and thank you all for watching and
listening at home we'll see you very
soon with another brilliant interview
like this one or rochelle and they
always go out at 7pm uk time 2 p.m
eastern standard or for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our local community using the
link below